also I don't know if this is the thing
necessarily about girls but it's always
moms right okay moms in particular
no when you've lost a little bit of
weight or you've gained a little bit of
weight even if you're not aware of it
it's just like every time it's like I
could be meaning like a friend's mom or
like you know a friend you know just
some mum of a friend that I know or
whatever
yeah I meet a lot of moms you know yeah
I should probably I should bring you
along yeah
and they're always just like you gained
a bit of weight or you've lost a bit of
weight and I'm like no I haven't we're
like listen and then I go home and I
check and I'm like wow I have lost a bit
away how the [__] did you know I feel
like there's a that's an Asian mom thing
they can they can always tell they have
they have like a scale in their minds
Asian mum conversation started 101 bro
there are some mom abilities that I just
don't [__] understand like how is it
okay how is it that you've misplaced
something you've spent the entire
[__] day looking for this like mobile
phone or keys or something that you've
misplaced you're like Mom I don't know
what this is they have a [__] radar
built into their mind to be like I know
we've misplaced it I'm gonna find it
within one second has like superhuman
abilities with that [__] like I could be
like something super insignificant like
oh I do you know where the roll of tape
is I [__] searched everywhere in this
house and she's just sitting on the
couch being like uh my room second
drawer right at the back and I go there
and it's there I'm like
I put like trackers on everything that's
important yeah you do I have trackers on
my wallet I have trackers on uh my
expensive headphones I have trackers on
my keys my passport my bike yeah I have
like a track on everything that's kind
of valuable and I need because it's not
even that I I got tired of losing it
potentially like permanently it was like
I was tired of that [__] five minute
[__] where I left to look around my
house yeah to find where it is I'm like
you know what I just want to get rid of
that I'm just gonna have it so that if I
lose it I'm like all right let's play I
I've done this thing now where I've had
the exact same problem because I had a
bad habit of just leaving [__] all over
the house I now have this thing where I
just have this one little box that just
has all my important [__] in it no I I I
have that too but I somehow just still
lose it I put [__] in the wrong place
sometimes skill issue so uh yeah that's
been very helpful for me
um except I have these like running
headphones that I like as well and the
two small to put a tracker on yeah and
so I keep losing them still and it's
driving me insane I I tried that once
um and then how do you trackers work so
do you have like a beeper yeah it's a
good thing and it plays a little ringing
sound the tile things yeah yeah I've
taught I I don't think they're as good
as the uh Apple one but yeah
um they work well enough yeah I lost the
thing that beeps like so oh it's just an
app on my phone oh it's just an app yeah
I'd probably lose my phone to like wow
I'd lose the thing to find the thing
that I've lost it's the best thing I
need my keys where's my phone [__]
where's my phone here's the best thing
about it if you have any of the things
there's a botnot you can double tap and
then it rings your phone oh for example
let me show you so I'm gonna okay yeah
this is an advertise like my wallet
right I have this this card that goes in
there yeah then I press this button
twice
whatever
oh cool and that's my phone yeah yeah
that's how it works see how easy isn't
that easy okay but here's the question
what if you lose your phone and your
wallet then as long as I have one item
that's still my bike my keys my passport
right as long as I have something that I
can then I'll be fine all right see I I
feel like because uh I I do have I do
have a finder and uh
um like Aki I I I feel like there must
be like some it must be something to do
with maternal instincts right because
yeah what I've noticed is that when we
first started dating for like almost 10
years now she wasn't she was as [__] as
me she was she just didn't know where
she would place things I would ask her
if she'd seen one certain thing that I'd
misplaced and she would nowhere near
find it and then in like the past two
three years she suddenly just gained
this ability to be like uh yeah uh your
keys are in the top drawer by your beds
uh you left them there and I'm like how
the [__] do you know this how when did
you develop this ability
and I'm like they're playing Sims in
Creative yeah yeah yeah you see the
whole house from like down being like
it's right there
and I'm like oh no is this is this a mom
thing that's like being developed it
must be is this a maternal is this a
superpower that is definitely not a dad
thing it is not a dab thing at all we're
just getting stupider maybe or it's a
dad thing where like the mum thing is
the Superhuman strength to find [__] the
dad thing is the Superhuman strength to
lose [__]
so it just balances out perfectly
idea that every time you just come you
get stupider your body thinks like
you're becoming a dad you're just like
oh you're a dad so now you become every
time you nut you just lose an IQ point
yay all right do you feel like you are
more like your mum or your dad or
somewhere perfectly in between
[Music]
so we didn't know how to tell you this
song but you did it for us maybe more
like my mom I feel like I'm nothing like
my dad I don't know it's very tough
right do you feel like you have a lot of
common with your mom and dad I feel like
when I was when I was like a kid right I
was way more like my mum I don't know I
I had like a
I think that's very common with Suns
though yeah like like I think like Suns
when you're younger you yeah very much
you know go after your mom yeah even in
terms of like looks as well yeah and
then as you get older you start to look
more like your dad because I was
definitely that like when I was a kid I
looked like full [__] Japanese kid I
looked exactly like my mom yeah and as
I'm getting old I'm looking less like my
mom more like my dad I feel like that
that way in personality as well yeah the
more I go the more I grow older the more
I'm like [__] you know [__] this is
something my dad would do so this is
something my dad would say and my mom my
mom's I'm gonna call my mom for us like
my mom's been like in full [__] copia
mode for the past like three years
because I'm like I keep doing things I'm
like I feel like I'm becoming my dad my
mom's like no you're still like me okay
you're still like me you're still my son
you're more like me you're more like me
and I'm like my I think I'm becoming
more my dad I'm not gonna lie my mom's
just like pointed it out why does my mum
want you to be more like you I don't
know I don't know it's just the pride
yeah it's just it's just the problem
yeah you should develop more things from
me because I am more yeah I've been
noticing like I even sound like my dad
now it's to the point where I pick up
the phone and people think it's my dad
sometimes yeah I have that too did you
have that as well yeah my grandma
mistook me for my dad once I've never
heard that yeah it's it's scary and also
just like there's just the small little
things that you notice is just normal
now until someone points it out being
like you didn't used to do that like
even just like doing that thing of like
when you come back home and you sit down
you you make that kind of oh like Sam
like I never used to do that well my
favorite thing is there's a there's a
shot of you as you like I don't know why
you I think you're in one of your manga
coffee videos you're like looking at
like the books yeah yeah you're looking
at it like shut your [__] old man
and like the you're like you're holding
like your one hand in the pocket one
hand on coffee going
there are so many times where I find
myself now in everyday life doing the
the dad uh the dad stand yeah where you
just kind of when you're looking at
things you're just like
laughs
like that's like what is this
I have notice you've been doing that
actually I never used to do that so I'm
getting old I hate it
is it just like you you reach a certain
age and just every dad just agrees to
like do the same thing and have like the
same sense of humor must be as well it
must be did you do you think Dad jokes
are actually dad jokes or were they
funny at their age and then they just
couldn't stop me no I've I've just come
to the conclusion now that dad jokes
used to be not funny now I find them
[__] hilarious
look look it's the irony thing it's the
irony cycle where you start saying
something ironically and you're like I'm
saying it ironically because haha I'm
getting old and then somewhere along the
line I start saying it because I
actually I say it I'm like I start
laughing to myself I'm like
like it's no longer ironic yeah you get
to the point where you say something in
a facetious tone not only because you
want the message to come across but you
also just find it hilarious
well you're just like you say something
facetious and then there's a voice in
the back of your head that was like nice
one Joey
you know what I mean right oh my God I
hate that we're able to oh my God no I'm
not I'm not becoming like myself you'll
get there you'll get I'm not I'm not I
don't think I'll ever get though you'll
get there don't worry you're British
I won't I'll always be fun
I'll always be hip with the kids I'll
always be one with their fellow
generational kids
I feel like I feel like as you know
if you don't have YouTube If you don't
have YouTube you'd probably grow more
into like your dad I get that I get that
Legend yeah you know it does he does
very chilled very relaxed you know as
like one most he he's a bloke man he's a
bloke you know enough
just living his best life man watching
football drinking beer that's what he
does meanwhile I'm just becoming more
and more like my dad and it's like I
don't know if that's a good thing or not
because my dad's pretty cool but yeah
yeah it's uh warring yeah I'm definitely
becoming like my dad I've realized The
more I've grown all of them like the
more my dad just finds comfort in just
doing nothing and just being chill with
life and it's like for him to like go
out and do something it's like my mum
that has to like pressure him to be like
oh let's go here let's go visit this
person and it's not like my dad doesn't
enjoy it but my dad will refuse my dad
will never do it if it's just by his own
volition and I'm like [__] this is this
is just me and Sydney the moment the
moment you guys can start calling me out
is if we ever go out drinking and then
in mid-conversation I go oh sorry boys
I'm [__] [__] face I remember you did
that once do you remember that you did
that once and I was like and I was like
I remember telling you there's always
one thing I want to adopt because you
want you are [__] facing like Joey you
just you you did the die you did exactly
the same thing as you that's your dad
God damn it oh man the race Just Gonna
Keep increasing as I get older
sake